and for the other side we are now joined
by democratic congressman from
massachusetts and member of the house
transportation and infrastructure
committee
jake auchenklaus congressman thanks for
taking time on saturday and it's great
to have
another member of the same committee
transportation and infrastructure just
the other side
of the aisle so let me just pick up
where congressman crawford left off
uh saying that speaker pelosi could be
holding this
all hostage as the senate right now as
we speak
working on the legislation working on
the bill for the 1.2
trillion dollar actual infrastructure
deal but yet speaker pelosi says
that she won't take up anything until
both pieces
are sent over past in the senate that
being the three and a half
trillion dollar budget reconciliation is
this
congressman in trouble where do things
stand as far as you see it
in the house caucus good afternoon good
to be with you
democrats and president biden put a down
payment
on infrastructure with the american
rescue plan sending 350 billion dollars
to states and cities that they can use
for
for water and for coveted recovery and
we're going to finish
our commitment with this bipartisan
infrastructure bill
there's lots of zigs and zags ahead of
us lots of negotiations but we are going
to pass policy that fixes roads and
bridges that ensures clean water for the
next generation
that guarantees high-speed internet to
connect people to the 21st century
economy
we will pass it and it is going to lower
costs for working families and make the
american worker the most productive in
the world
congressman if you will we're just we
have this rare live
senate session you have senator
elizabeth warren talking now on the
senate floor she has come not to talk
about infrastructure but about
evictions let's take a quick listen on
rental payments
last year congress worked together to
account for that staggering reality
we provided more than 45 billion dollars
in emergency rental assistance
that money is now finally getting into
the hands of
landlords around the country it's
helping families who lost
jobs get caught up on the missed
payments
but the money is getting out too slowly
some states and local governments open
their assistance programs only
last month some hadn't spent a single
dollar
by the beginning of june now that's
starting to change in june states
delivered more than one and a half
billion dollars in emergency rental
assistance
that money went to help nearly 300 000
households
but there are still billions of dollars
to distribute
and millions of families in need
we have the tools and we have the
funding
what we need is the time look
i agree that the eviction moratorium is
not
a long-term solution but let me be very
clear
it is the right short-term action
it's how we keep families safely in
their homes while states deliver
emergency aid it's how we keep families
who are
starting to recover from the worst
economic crisis of their lifetimes
get back on their feet millions of jobs
elizabeth talking about the expiration
today
of the federal ban on evictions because
of the pandemic
congressman i want to bring you back in
your thoughts
on really where we are in respect to
both those evictions and the larger
picture you have in your home state and
provincetown
an outbreak of this delta variant kovind
spike
as the senator said congress has
approved
tens of billions of dollars for tenant
and landlord relief
i am going to be working and i'm already
in contact with state and local
officials
to ensure that we can disperse those
funds expeditiously and fairly
to prevent unjust evictions i think it's
important
though to really ground ourselves and
why are we in this situation
the first wave of covid was a surprise
the second wave was seasonal the third
wave geographic
but this fourth wave this is a choice
this is a choice
that republicans are making they're
suing speaker pelosi over mass mandates
they are undermining basic science
instead of directly
communicating to their constituents and
saying what i will say now this vaccine
is safe this vaccine is effective
get a vaccine to protect yourself and to
protect the ones that you love
but congressman we've seen many most of
the notable
republican leaders like uh steve scalise
and others
saying hey vaccines work i got a vaccine
get a vaccine but yet
you do have this fight going on a line
drawn in the sand by
house republicans over wearing masks
saying that speaker pelosi is engaging
in what appears to be
a power grab in fact just in the last
show on
cavuto live charles payne was talking to
republican congresswoman nancy mace and
she had this video where
she basically said come and make me do
it you know i'm not going to put the
mask on
so what is your what do you say to
republicans that that are drawing a line
in the sand
speaker pelosi leader schumer are
listening to medical professionals and
public health experts
we are in this situation we are faced
with a series
of frustrating options because we are
not
doing what we know works and taking the
very best option which is to prevent
outbreaks in the first place by adopting
the vaccine i heard your previous guest
he was trying to undermine the cdc's
public health guidance he was blaming
speaker pelosi for mass mandates
i didn't hear him tell his constituents
i didn't hear him tell your viewers that
the vaccine
is safe and that it is the most
effective way that we can all get to the
other side of this pandemic
i'm frustrated with mass mandates too i
don't want to wear a mask anymore i
don't want to go back into lockdowns
i don't want my kids to be exposed to
delta we know what works
it's a vaccine congressman are you
concerned you you mentioned
something that's on a lot of americans
minds right now and that's
lockdowns at the white house this week i
was at the press briefing on thursday
deputy
white house press secretary korean
jean-pierre not ruling out the
possibility that
lockdowns could come because they will
follow the science of the white house
they will listen to the cdc
are you concerned we could be facing
another lockdown
elected officials top priority needs to
be the health and safety
of the american people we have to leave
every option
on the table when we are faced with a
fourth wave
of a potentially even more infectious
and more fatal variant of the of this
virus
nobody wants lockdowns everybody agrees
that lockdowns
is the worst and last option the very
first and best option is a vaccine to
prevent these outbreaks in the first
place
that needs to be the focus let's have
another good day like we did yesterday
have another million shots in arms
congressman jake and kloss from
massachusetts thank you for taking time
and your input we will
have you back as this infrastructure
deal is a
long ways away from being done thank you
sir thank you